على كل حال الحديث عن الهيمنه الايرانيه
طويله ويطول اكثر والمتضرر الاول هو
المواطن العراقي الذي بات مرغما على
التعاطي مع المنتجات والخدمات الايرانيه
حسره طيران اتعملوا على ضرب الاقتصاد
العراقي وتحويله الى اقتصاد المستهلك
واغراق السوق العراقي
بصناعاتها ومنتجاتها مثلا البضائع التي
تمر عبر الحدود من ايران الى العراق لا
تخضع للفحص او المواصفات والمقاييس شهاده
المنشا قد تكون كافيه لعمرها اما في مجال
الطاقه تمكنت ايران من رفع صادراتها
النفطيه الى العراق مثلا بدايه العام 2018
من 30% الى 50% بعد عمليه التدمير ومن
منهج للمصافي النفسيه في مدينه صلاح الدين
العراقيه اثناء تحريرها تنظيم داعش وفي
ازمه الكهرباء ايران تزود العراق بثلث
حاجاته من الغاز والكهرباء وبالمناسبه
يحرق العراق اكثر من مليار ونصف لمليار
قدم مكعب من الغاز المصاحب للنفط يوميا اي
10 اضعاف الكميه المستورده من ايران بقيمه
تقدر بنحو مليرين ونصف المليار دولار
سنويا ودهون الاستفاده منه
تنشطوا ايران ايضا في قطاع الفندق حتى بات
المستثمرون الايرانيون المهيمنون على
المشاريع الكبرى في مدينتي كربلاء والنجف
اضافه الى السيطره الايرانيه على قطاع
النقل البري والجوي